Before I talk about discrete mathematics, I want
us to first talk about pure mathematics
because I want to start with two important definitions
to important terms to which we will
be making reference throughout this workshop.
And in fact, you'll be
finding references to these words throughout mathematical literature.
Okay so far if you remember what I said that I said there are two obstacles.
When you learn mathematics number one is the
symbols number tools the terminology where we'll
we're addressing the terminology right here.
and right now
a mathematical object
and this is a very
high level definition
Okay.
A mathematical object is something.
That you can put inside the collection.
And to which certain?
operations apply
now, this is a very
That's a vague definition, but I'll
give you an example of what a mathematical object is.
And integer or integers.
Integers are objects that you can
put inside a collection.
The integer number system is a collection of integers.
And these are objects to which you can apply operations like addition.
Subtraction multiplication, right? These
are things you can do to integers. So that's one example
for mathematical objects real numbers.
Are also mathematical objects or complex numbers?
sets our mathematical objects
Matrices vectors tensors we have
these things called spaces.
And Fields and groups and Rings. These are
words from abstract algebra. You may have heard of these. If not,
you definitely want to
you know put time aside to also be clear with these
with with Concepts in
abstract algebra, which I'll also come
to
so that's a mathematical object. I give you some examples.
By the way, if you're watching this.
Look at check out the video description where there will
be a link to.
a document
where
these
you know words that I'm using these.
Terminologies to which I'm referring.
Will be defined in that document.
And they will be accompanied with examples. So if I
say if I, you know, say the word
space and then you want to know what that means. You
can check the video description go to that link. You'll find
the definition for that word and an example to make
especially clear what that word means.
So that's a mathematical object.
Now then we have something called a mathematical structure.
a mathematical structure is
something that contains a mathematical object.
Again, a set can also be a mathematical structure.
if
have experienced programming.
Like a python we have these things called lists and
sets and tuples right you can put elements
at them.
Well, you know then a python a list cannot only
contain things but it's but a list itself
can be put into another list.
So and the same is true for I said,
so I said itself is a mathematical object, but it
can also be put inside another.
Mathematical object so you can have a set inside a set.
now
the outermost set
we call the structure and the
Its elements we call a mathematical object.
So it's relative.
Okay.
And once again, we will look at an example of this to make it very
clear. What?
I mean by these words.
So here's an example. This is a set.
In math, we indicate sets with curly brackets.
And it has in it some objects. What are these
objects while they're integers? 1 2 3 4 5
so these are mathematical objects.
And the set that contains what we call a mathematical structure.
pretty easy
Okay.
So let keep those are words in mind
because we will be making reference as to those
words as we go along in the subsequent slides.
What is pure mathematics?
And I'm sure or I assume you've
heard of something called Applied Mathematics, and you may wonder what?
These two are and how they are.
different from each other